my gross micro cheating it's not like
cheating cheating
[Music]
so micro cheating occurs when someone
goes a little bit outside the lines of
what is allowed in a relationship and
there's some deception there closing the
computer when someone walks in they're
not sharing everything with their
partners that they're sharing with
someone else
couples have all kinds of arrangements
what's normal in a relationship is
what's normal to the couple some people
would say you can't even have dinner
with someone you're attracted to but
others would say that it's totally fine
to have innocent flirtation so those
boundaries really need to be set within
the couple think you swear that we will
get through this okay just seal it up do
you feel like a little jealous eight
times I call like I see it you're just
really nice and friendly so I think
sometimes people like take it the wrong
way well we have these cards one side is
cheating and the other side means it's
all good is it okay to follow an
excellent social media I think it's an
impediment for people right after you
break up hopefully you're not like
checking it on things on a daily basis
[Music]
no I think it's okay because sometimes
yeah X this needs to see that you doing
way better than like it's just it's like
harmless unless you had some crazy
relationship or breakup I follow my ex
[Music]
liking an exit picture depends I would
like good day look are bad that's a bad
shouldn't matter it's either like it's a
bad picture that's all like it so it
gets to the top of the feed sometimes
you might just be scrolling and then
your phone folders and it's like oh I
left the heart on the picture I mean
it's like oh really and then I would
immediately go back and UNTAC just so
it's clear though you know that was a
powerful communicating with a Texas
family who does that I don't know not me
I don't even talk to my whole family
that much so I do this
I got affirmed not cheating on this one
your mom still talks to your exes I
don't think it's cheating but I think
it's like a little bit inappropriate I
feel like if god forbid if anything like
happened to us like I'd still want to
know your family just because I really
like them
having a false name in your context why
would you change a name if there wasn't
something wrong you just spare people's
feelings a little bit like so even if
you're not into the person like you
might just change their name just to
avoid an argument some girls are like
read into something too much like Oh
who's Janet you know and it'll be
completely nothing but you don't even
want to go there I've never done it to
you if you are changing someone's
information to like the pizza store or
something like that like this admitting
to you being guilty of doing shady
things yes that's your side piece having
a work life at work husband mm-hmm
you're emotionally cheating like there
should be no work - there should be no
other husband than this husband I don't
think he likes this because we met at
work so this probably is like this is
close all okay if you're like putting
the wife or husband on the end of any
one that's not your person then that's
success using heart or kiss emojis no no
what if it's like like a guy you've been
friends up for a long time I don't okay
like if someone d-ends you all you can
do like instead of a like button it's a
hard fun real question here is why
Indians in the first place okay there's
this stay away from the kiss you know
know like getting people's pictures and
stuff with hearts or like you're looking
good or something like that sometimes
people just you don't need to know
they're looking good some days I can see
that like if you're like yeah we have
pretty similar answer you I was kind of
surprised I thought you're gonna think
like nothing was micro cheating we're
clear when I like our boundaries and
what like makes us upset you know what
affects that the persons were friends
before we even got into relationship we
talk like wow it's a thing couple should
do Michael Tiemann is definitely saying
definitely something that could be
detrimental to
I feel like you give me flowers